Also Boykotte sollten mit Augenmaß, mit einem
Verantwortungsgefühl verbunden sein.
Abgesehen von dem aktuellen
Russland Angriffskrieg ja, aber das finde
ich gerade echt schwierig an der Diskussion.
Wir können doch nicht über
T-Shirts aus Bangladesh das genau
deswegen gleichen Maße über die Ukraine
und die Friedensbewegung. Ich übrigens
auch. Deswegen habe ich gesagt,
wir bleiben am Anfang bei Russland
und gehen danach weiter. Ne, ne, ne, ne,
das müssen wir. Das musst du
uns zugestehen. 13 Fragen. Hier kommt
die erste: Müssen wir Autokratien
viel strenger boykottieren? Wenn ihr sagt
tendenziell eher ja, dann
bitte auf dem grünen Feld Platz nehmen
oder positionieren. Und wenn ihr sagt
Nee, lieber nicht, dann bitte auf dem gelben
Feld und bitte! So, vielen Dank. Jetzt
wissen wir, wo ihr steht. Große Frage ist,
wo steht ihr eigentlich, Autokraten -
soweit ich weiß, fast alles Männer - sind
ja mehr oder weniger Alleinherrscher.
Das heißt, Meinungs- und Pressefreiheit sowie
Rechtsstaatlichkeit spielen,
wenn überhaupt, als Fassade eine Rolle.
Trotzdem machen wir lupenreinen
Demokraten natürlich gerne Geschäfte mit ihnen.
Erstens wegen des Geldes,
zweitens wegen des Geldes und drittens
aus einer ernsthaften politischen
Überzeugung heraus, dass nämlich Wandel
entstehen kann durch Handel. Das Beispiel
Russland hat gezeigt: Das stimmt so nicht
immer. Im Gegenteil haben wir jetzt
die härtesten Sanktionen aller Zeiten.
Wir boykottieren quasi alles, bis auf das bisschen
Öl und Gas jeden Tag für mehrere
100 Millionen €. Aber auch das wird
ja diskutiert gerade. Das heißt, wir müssen
uns ganz generell fragen Wie wollen
wir zukünftig mit derlei Staaten umgehen,
also mit Katar, mit China, mit der Türkei?
Die einen sagen, jetzt ist die Zeit
für eine Zeitenwende. Wir müssen
radikal umdenken und viel strenger und viel härter
boykottieren. Am besten alle
Autokratien auf der Welt. Die anderen sagen: Nee,
so einfach ist es nicht. Wir müssen
auch weiter in Wirtschaftsbeziehungen bleiben,
damit die zarte Pflanze Demokratie
vielleicht am Ende sogar noch eine Chance
hat. Wir werden bei dieser Folge keine
finale Antwort finden, aber vielleicht so
eine Art Faustregel, eine grobe
Orientierung. Wer weiß, vielleicht finden
diese beiden Parteien am Ende auch einen
Kompromiss. Wir werden sehen. Jetzt erst
mal die Frage an euch Wo würdet ihr euch
positionieren? Ganz spontan grün?
Viel strenger boykottieren. Oder gelb? Lieber weiter in Wirtschaftsbeziehungen bleiben. Schreibt's mir gerne in die Kommentare!
So, die Spielregeln sind
ganz einfach. Wenn ihr der Gegenseite
in irgendeinem Punkt zustimmt, dann
könnt ihr auf sie zugehen, indem ihr einen
Schritt nach vorne macht. Und wenn ihr sagt:
Grundsätzlich finde ich das gar
nicht so schlecht, was du sagst,
aber das ist wirklich Bullshit. Dann könnt
ihr auch einen Schritt zurückgehen.
Mein Ziel wäre, euch am Ende der Folge hier
vorne alle in einer Art
Kompromiss Feld zu versammeln, in der Hoffnung,
dass wir irgendwie eine Linie
finden, wo wir uns einig werden. Und ich weiß,
bei diesem Thema müssen wir an jeder
Stelle immer wieder neu differenzieren,
könnt auch gerne hin- und herlaufen,
wie es euch beliebt. Die große Frage,
die wir natürlich heute haben, ist auf der einen
Seite eine allgemeine Faustregel:
Wie umgehen mit Autokratien im Allgemeinen?
Und natürlich starten
wir aber erst mal mit dem Konkreten.
Wir haben gerade einen russischen
Angriffskrieg, da ist ja die Sachlage
vielleicht noch ein bisschen anders.
Frage Nummer zwei und die geht
an Arthur: Du hast Familie und Freunde
in der Ukraine. Du hast da viele
Bände. Ich glaube, sogar, deine Freundin ist
ukrainisch. Wie gehst du aktuell mal
ganz allgemein gesagt mit Russland-Boykotten
um? Sagst du all in oder muss
man da schon differenzieren?
Nun sagen wir es mal so: All in hätte
man aus meiner Perspektive von Anfang
an machen müssen. Die Problematik
ist aber eher, warum ich jetzt hier bin
in dieser Position, dass wir nicht alle
autokratischen Regime durch durch die Bank
weg boykottieren können. Wenn wir jetzt
alle Autokratien boykottieren und noch
viel konsequenter als wir es gerade
tun, dann könnte das Problem entstehen,
der Blockbildung. Das bedeutet,
dass bestimmte autokratische Staaten sich
zusammenschließen und ein Gegengewicht
zu unseren westlichen demokratischen
Grundordnung bilden. Das ist
die Problematik dahinter.
-Und warum ist das bei Russland anders?
-Es ist ein Angriffskrieg, es ist ein
radikaler Angriffskrieg. Er ist
schon nicht seit heute da. Die Eskalation gab
es schon im Donbass nach der Maidan
Revolution und jetzt ist sozusagen
-das Fass übergelaufen.
-Und hätte man deiner Meinung nach schon
vor acht Jahren sagen müssen:
Wir müssen viel härter sanktionieren?
Ja, natürlich, man hätte es sagen
sollen, man hätte es tun sollen. Das Problem ist
bei der ganzen Debatte, dass Deutschland
aus meiner Perspektive nicht klug
gehandelt hat. Also meine Meinung ist,
dass man bei Boykotten klug handeln sollte
und wissen, mit wem
man redet und wie man redet.
Katja: Was glaubst du, haben wir gerade?
Handeln wir gerade klug im Russland
Ukraine Krieg? Wir handeln viel zu langsam,
wir handeln viel zu schwach,
wir handeln inkonsequent und vor allem
müssen wir als deutsche Person,
als deutsche Staatsangehörige, auch Fehler
einräumen. Fehler der Vergangenheit,
die dahingehend auch passiert
sind. Und das richtet sich natürlich
auch an unsere wirtschaftlichen
Interessen, die wir weiterhin
und trotz vieler Warnungen seit
vielen, vielen Jahren mit Russland geführt haben.
Über die Nord Stream Projekte, aber
natürlich auch über viele, viele andere
wirtschaftliche Beziehungen haben
wir das, was heute in der Ukraine passiert,
auch möglich gemacht. Wir sollten
Autokratien auf jeden Fall boykottieren,
weil die für unzählige
Menschenrechtsverletzungen verantwortlich
sind. Wenn wir sie nicht
boykottieren, dann lassen wir ihnen freie Hand,
das zu tun, was sie wollen. Und das kann
nicht in unserem Interesse sein. Jetzt ist
es ja vollkommen eindeutig bei dieser Sache,
die größten und die wesentlichen
Opfer des Krieges und die Menschen in der Ukraine.
Andererseits sagen viele auch na
ja, jetzt haben wir diese heftigen
Boykotte und auch die russische
Bevölkerung, die unbeteiligte
Bevölkerung ist davon betroffen. Also leere
Geldautomaten, Wirtschaftsboykotte
treffen auch die Menschen. Der Rubel ist fast
nichts mehr wert usw. Wie bewertest
du das? Ist das ein Kollateralschaden,
den man hinnehmen muss? Also ich möchte
erst mal sagen, dass kein einziges
Schicksal gerade mit dem zu vergleichen
ist, was in der Ukraine passiert.
Mariupol ist komplett vernichtet. Es ist
ein Vernichtungskrieg mit dem russischen
imperialistischen Ziel, die Ukraine
für immer von der Landkarte zu löschen.
Das bedeutet auch unser Komfort
hier in Deutschland ist nicht
mit dem zu vergleichen, was gerade in der Ukraine
passiert. Das ist das erste.
Das zweite ist, was die Bevölkerung
angeht, auch da muss man natürlich
differenzieren, auch da muss man
natürlich schauen, wen trifft was. Aber letztlich,
seien wir noch mal ganz ehrlich,
müssen wir gerade alles tun, um die Ukraine
zu verteidigen. Geht ihr auf sie zu?
Stimmt ihr zu? Artur Ja. Dorothea zögert
so ein bisschen. Warum? Ja, weil ich dieses Argument
mit der Zivilbevölkerung,
die jetzt auch geschädigt wird
wirklich mir ein bisschen zu Herzen nehme,
wenn ich höre, dass zum Beispiel
McDonald's in Russland mehrere 10.000
Zulieferer hat, Bauern, die jetzt
eben keinen Abnehmer mehr haben. Dann frage
ich mich schon, inwiefern diese Maßnahme
hilft, wenn Macron sich aus Russland jetzt
zurückzieht. Vor allem auch,
inwiefern sie dazu beiträgt, wirklich
den Ukrainekonflikt zu lösen, weil sie nicht
eine staatsnahe Branche ist,
unter der dann Putin direkt leidet,
wenn die verschwindet oder Putin wahrscheinlich
auch kein Interesse persönlich an Big
Macs hat. Das heißt, da frage ich mich schon,
ob wir bei diesen Sachen nicht am Ziel
vorbei schießen und nicht Menschen
der Möglichkeit berauben, eine menschenwürdige
Existenz zu führen,
weil wir einfach quasi mit Kanonen
auf Spatzen schießen. Und ich bin
für Sanktionen, aber dort, wo sie dem Regime
wehtun und nicht dort,
wo sie in erster Linie der Zivilbevölkerung
schaden. Ich bin
überzeugt, dass Wandel in Autokratien
primär durch Austausch entsteht und nicht
durch Boykott. Denken wir nur an Korea,
das am stärksten abgeschottete Land
der Welt. Wie geht es den Leuten
dort? Sie hungern. Sie leben unter miserablen
Umständen ein Aufstand gegen Kim Jong
Un ist nicht in Sicht, so viel ich weiß.
Von daher denke ich, wenn schon
Wandel, dann durch Handel und ohne Handel
garantiert kein Wandel. Stimmt ihr zu?
Bitte, wer will da? Das heißt, du würdest
sagen McDonald's Boykotte
brauchen wir nicht unbedingt.
Also meine Position ist ja eigentlich
eher, dass wenn schon Boykott, dann immer
Boykott. Ja, also die Unterscheidung
oder auch die etwas heuchlerische
Unterscheidung zwischen wo wird
boykottiert, wo wird nicht boykottiert,
hängt ja sehr davon ab, wo wir gerade
hinschauen. Also wenn wir jetzt sozusagen
Russland boykottieren, um das Gas von Saudiarabien
zu bekommen, tauschen wir de
facto einen Diktator durch einen
anderen oder ein totalitäres Regime durch
ein anderes. Wir haben nur leider
sehr viele autoritäre Regime auf der Erde,
Saudi Arabien, China und viele
andere mehr. Wenn wir die alle
aus den Handelsbeziehungen
rausnehmen, dann wäre die Welt eine andere.
Aber prinzipiell sollten
Demokratien es verhindern, vermeiden, mit Regimen,
die autoritär sind, totalitär sind
und zumal solchen, die Kriege führen,
Handelsbeziehungen zu treiben.
Aber ich bin natürlich auch der Meinung,
dass wenn man über Boykotte spricht,
dann geht man eher davon aus, dass man über
den Boykott einen anderen Diktator
oder Tyrannen oder was auch immer autoritären
Führer zu irgendwas zwingt. Aber
natürlich nicht die Zivilbevölkerung. Ja, das ist ja
immer die schmale Gratwanderung. Also
dass jetzt russische Kinder kein Playmobil
haben, das finde ich auch einfach
unschön. Und dann trifft es einfach immer
die Falschen. Und genau diese Differenzen
wollen wir hier ja ausdifferenzieren.
Darum geht es ja. Melina, du
schüttelt so ein bisschen mit dem Kopf herum. Ja,
also bei manchen Sachen dachte ich mir
Ja, da gehe ich voll mit. Bei anderen Sachen
dachte ich mir Oh mein Gott, ich versuche
es mal so zusammen zu fassen. Also ich bin
auch absolut der Meinung, dass man das konsequent
sein soll. Und wenn wir sagen,
wir sollten alle autokratischen
Regime oder von mir aus auch alle Regime,
die Menschenrechtsverletzungen
krasse Menschenrechtsverletzungen machen,
sollten wir boykottieren. Da stimme
ich voll zu. Das einzige, wo ich mir denke so
russische Kinder haben jetzt
kein Playmobil, ich weiß, das war nur so
ein Beispiel, aber ich meine, ich hatte
als Kind nicht mal Eltern, ich hatte
nichts. Ich habe es leider an eigener
Haut erfahren, was passiert, wenn man
autokratische Regime nicht boykottiert
und ihnen nichts entgegensetzt. Denn ich bin
aus Bosnien. Ich musste von dort
fliehen wegen des Genozids, der dort passierte.
Vier Jahre lang Konzentrationslager,
Vernichtungslager, Vergewaltigungslager,
die längste Belagerung einer Hauptstadt
in der modernen Weltgeschichte. All das ist
bei uns passiert, vier Jahre lang.
Alle wussten es, und niemand hat was getan.
Und deshalb sehe ich es als meine Pflicht,
jetzt zu helfen, wenn Menschen weltweit
das Gleiche oder ähnliches durchmachen
müssen. Weil ich weiß, der größte Schmerz
ist, wenn niemand überhaupt versucht
zu helfen. Sie sagt, McDonalds boykottieren
ist der falsche Weg. Trifft trifft
eher die falschen und eben nicht das Regime.
Wenn ich dich richtig verstanden
habe, sagst du Naja kommt Leute jetzt,
jetzt lieber einmal
konsequent durchziehen. Trifft vielleicht
auch ein bisschen die Falschen,
aber das nimmt man dann hin. Was sagst du?
Vielleicht würde ich vor kurz
erklären, warum ich mich eher auf diese Seite
positioniert habe. Das hat mit der Art
zu tun, wie ihr die Frage formuliert habt
und mit zwei Begriffen Das eine ist
autokratisches Regime, weil das eben
auch ein bisschen so sozusagen synonym
verhandelt wurde, eine Autokratie. Was ist
eine Autokratie, was ist eine Diktatur?
Was ist ein totalitäres Regime? Das ist
nicht nur eine politikwissenschaftliche
Unterscheidung, das ist sozusagen
auch für Strategien, auch für politische
Strategien macht das einen Unterschied,
ob man mit einem Land, sagen wir mal,
mit der Türkei zu tun hat oder auch Venezuela,
autokratische Regime, die aber
ihre Legitimität daraus beziehen,
gewählt worden zu sein, die deswegen den Schein
von Institutionen
wie einer kritischen Öffentlichkeit,
wie eine unabhängige Gerichtsbarkeit usw
aufrechterhalten, wo es auch gewisse
Räume gibt, auch für Opposition.
Auch wenn das immer sozusagen
einer Willkürherrschaft unterworfen ist
oder eine Diktatur wie China das ist,
das ist ein Unterschied. Und ich glaube,
Russland ist gerade dabei, von dem einen
zum anderen zu kippen. Wenn wir alle
autokratische Regime in der Welt
boykottieren, dann würden wir natürlich
in einer Welt leben, die sehr viel
isolierter ist. Und das ist praktisch
nicht möglich, dass ist auch das Schwerste.
Wir stoßen immer wieder
auf Grenzen, das heißt Formen
von Zusammenarbeit sind notwendig.
Zum Beispiel ein Land, das ich sehr gut
kenne, in dem ich auch als Reporter
gearbeitet habe, nämlich die Türkei.
Die Türkei besteht ja nicht nur aus dem Regime
Erdogan, sondern einem Teil der Gesellschaft,
so um die 50 % oder so,
die das Regime ablehnen. Und und ich glaube
das Erdogan Regime, das wird nicht
für alle Zeiten existieren. Und die Frage
wo sich die hin wohin sich die Türkei,
wohin sich die türkische Gesellschaft
richten wird, diese Frage entscheidet sich
schon heute und der Westen steht vor der schwierigen
Aufgabe und Europa steht
vor der schwierigen Aufgabe,
Partner zu bleiben, ohne sich zum Komplizen
dieses Regimes zu machen. Leicht
gesagt, schwer getan. Aber genau das ist
die Aufgabe. Hättest du gefragt,
sollte man da härter rangehen? Ich hätte mich
auf der Seite positioniert, weil ich es auch falsch
finde. Zum Beispiel im Umgang
mit der Türkei bin ich. Ich bin nicht
für Wirtschaftssanktionen. Das ist auch das,
was türkische Oppositionelle immer
wieder sagen. Sie sind nicht dagegen,
wenn Siemens oder Daimler usw in der Türkei
investieren. Davon profitiert man
ja auch. Das bringt ja auch Jobs,
was die immer wieder sagen. Die sollen halt
auch Verantwortung übernehmen und sich
nicht zu Komplizen machen. Genau
deswegen bei dem wer die Formulierung
hätte das ein anderes Wort benutzt
als boykottieren, hätte ich mich dahin
gestellt. Und jetzt komme ich zu Russland
und dann auch zum Ende. Russland ist
ein anderer Punkt. Das wurde eben schon
gesagt. Es ist ein Angriffskrieg. Und warum?
Warum ist dann Boykott die richtige
Maßnahme? Und da geht es glaube ich nicht
darum, dass wir jetzt unser Gewissen
bereinigen. Also dieses, bei allem
Respekt, aber dieses protestantische
Gewissen stinkt, das ist nicht
meins. Das Ziel des Boykotts ist nicht weniger
als der Regime change. Es geht
darum, dieses System, dieses Regime auf allen
Ebenen, auf einer symbolischen,
also in der Kultur, im Sport und so weiter
zu ächten wie Südafrika
seinerzeit, aber auch mit allen anderen Mitteln,
auch mit wirtschaftlichen
Mitteln, natürlich auch mit Konsequenzen
für die Bevölkerung, die hässlich
sind. Da darf man sich auch nichts vormachen.
Aber das Ziel des Ganzen ist genau
so, wie es Joe Biden und das finde ich,
passiert auch nicht so oft, dass ich Joe
Biden zustimme. Aber er hat recht.
Das Ziel ist das Regime Change,
weil Russland hat mit diesem Angriffskrieg
eine Grenze überschritten, hinter die es auch kein
Zurück geben kann. Ich weiß
nicht, wie man sich das in der Bundesregierung
vorstellt. Nach meinem
Dafürhalten kann man mit Putin selbst
wenn dieser Krieg, wenn dieser Angriffskrieg
gegen die Ukraine am Ende
scheitern sollte, was wir glaube ich alle
sehr hoffen, wird man mit Russland
nicht einfach so weitermachen können. Das heißt,
du sagst Wirtschaftsboykott, du
sagst Sportboykott, du sagst Kultur,
wenn wir über Russland reden.
Dorothea ist davon nicht überzeugt. Warum nicht?
Wir haben es ja gerade gehört. Du
sagst ja nee, ich würde da differenzieren.
Ich stimme eigentlich auch wirklich
sehr vielem zu, was von drüben gesagt wurde.
Es vermischen sich die Grenzen, aber
der Punkt, den du erwähnst Unternehmen sollen
zum Beispiel bleiben in der Türkei
oder Verantwortung übernehmen. Genau
in diese Richtung haben wir uns in den letzten
Jahren entwickelt. Wir haben
die Globalisierung und den internationalen
Handel gestartet, ohne Rücksicht
auf Menschenrechte. Wir sind
dorthin gegangen, wo die Ware und die Menschen
am billigsten waren. Und irgendwann, so
in den letzten Jahren, ist das Bewusstsein
entstanden im Moment. Vielleicht
haben ja unsere westlichen Unternehmen
eine Verantwortung entlang ihrer
Lieferkette und können sich in ihren
exotischen Tochtergesellschaften
nicht total daneben benehmen. Inzwischen haben
wir Lieferkettengesetze in Deutschland.
Das heißt, wir haben jetzt Mechanismen,
mit denen wir Unternehmen zur Rechenschaft
ziehen können für Missstände entlang
der Produktionskette. Und es ist
nicht mehr einfach so voneinander getrennt,
so strikt voneinander getrennt. Wir haben
inzwischen eine Kultur, die ist jetzt doch
nicht wahnsinnig etabliert und die Rechtsprechung
muss auch noch folgen.
Aber wir haben da jetzt zarte
Maßnahmen ergriffen, um Globalisierung in ethisch
geordnete Bahnen zu lenken. Und dieses ganze
radikal boykottieren und eben
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen kappen
läuft dem zuwider und ist für mich
in dieser Hinsicht ein Rückschritt,
der viele Leute und zwar nicht in ihrer
Konsumentenrolle. Die Konsumentenrolle
ist mir ziemlich egal, ob jetzt Playmobil
oder Big Mac oder Billy
Regal, nicht in der Konsumenten Rolle,
sondern in der Rolle als Arbeitnehmer,
Zulieferer etc. wirklich wirklich
schädigt. Ihr wart gerade eben
relativ weit vorne. Jetzt seid ihr alle immer
weiter zurück. Vielleicht fangen wir mit Melina
an, dann kommt Katja, dann kommt
Ulrike. Deniz, ich muss sagen,
vieles von deiner Argumentation gehe
ich auch tatsächlich sehr mit. Alles
was angeht, wirtschaftliche Beziehungen
und dass die vermeintlich irgendwas
Diplomatisches bringen. Ich muss sagen,
aus persönlicher Erfahrung, aber
eben auch aus ganz, ganz vielen politischen
Diskussionen, daraus, dass ich vor Ort
war. Ich war vor Ort in Kasachstan
und habe dort mit Menschenrechtsaktivistin
gesprochen. Meine Familie kommt
aus Belarus. Ich habe Freunde aus der Ukraine.
Wandel durch Handel hat überhaupt
gar nichts gebracht, weil das Ganze
im Prinzip nur den Status quo weiter erhält
und der Status quo bedeutet Wir finanzieren
weiter diese Regime. Und man
darf sich nichts vormachen. Man
darf sich nicht vormachen, dass dieses Geld
irgendwie an die russische Bevölkerung
weitergeht. Das sind Oligarchen Strukturen
gerade, die sich dort vernetzt
haben, von denen wir auch wirtschaftlich hier
profitieren, muss ich auch wirklich
ganz ehrlich sagen. Was Gazprom angeht.
Was Lobbyismus angeht, ist, dass wir hier
davon profitiert haben. Das ist Nummer
eins. Und das andere ist Ich würde
mal gerne davon loskommen,
dass wir die russische Bevölkerung
von ihrer Verantwortung freisprechen,
weil da gibt es eine bedeutsamen
Mehrheit, die Putin und die diesen Angriffskrieg
unterstützt. Da sind Stadien voll
gewesen jetzt mit Putin Anhängern. Das sind
diejenigen wirklich, die seit- Das ist
total schwer zu beschreiben. Das ist
im Prinzip wie eine Sekte.
Und einen einzigen Menschen schon
aus dieser Propagandamaschinerie
rauszubringen, ist unfassbar schwierig.
Und natürlich ist nicht nur ein wirtschaftlicher
Boykott das einzige.
Das andere ist, Zivilgesellschaft zu fördern.
Das ist, freie Medien zu fördern.
Das ist kulturellen Austausch
letztlich auch zu fördern. Es ist viel,
was präventiv getan werden kann.
Aber jetzt gerade sind wir in einem
historischen, epochalen Umbruch. Und da finde
ich, meiner Meinung nach muss alles
auf dem Tisch liegen, alles, wo vorher
gesagt worden ist, nein, wissen wir nicht,
trauen wir uns nicht unbedingt ran.
Wir wollen jetzt mal schauen. Wir wollen
den diplomatischen Kurs gehen.
Die Appeasementpolitik ist gescheitert.
Und das ist mein Status quo, wo ich sage
Wir müssen über alles reden, wir müssen
über alles reden, und zwar von A bis Z.
Und da darf es keine Verbote mehr geben.
Wir müssen auf jeder erdenklichen
Ebene versuchen, diesen grausamen Krieg
zu stoppen. Also da habe ich ja
überhaupt kein Widerspruch. Also ich finde es so
ein bisschen schwierig, wenn wir sozusagen
so abstrakt über gleichermaßen über
den Iran, China, wir reden jetzt
über Russland. Wir reden jetzt nur über
Russland. Dann würde ich jetzt
so gerne rüber springen. Du bist hin
und hergelaufen, Artur. Du
warst erst da, erst dann wieder da.
Das war fast wie ein Tanz auf dem Vulkan
wegen Katia. Das Problem bei der ganzen
Geschichte ist Ich stimme Katia in fast
allen Punkten zu, aber gleichzeitig gibt
es ja auch diese Facette, dass wir in gewisser
Weise in Russland so
nach dem Zusammenbruch der Sowjetunion
so ein Ding hatten. Wir hatten so einen
Nullpunkt in Anführungszeichen, den ich wahrscheinlich
auch nicht gibt. Es gab
keine Lebensmittel, keine
Babynahrung, teilweise. Und dann kam der Handel,
dann kam sozusagen
dieses neo kapitalistische
innerhalb dieses russischen
Systems. Und dieses Wandel durch Handel hat uns
im Endeffekt auch gleichzeitig ein Instrument
gegeben, sozusagen Russland
wieder zurück in diese 90er, in diesen wilden
90er zurück zu sanktionieren,
was sehr, sehr tief in diesem kollektiven,
wie du wahrscheinlich selbst weißt,
Unterbewusstsein vorhanden ist. Also
die 90er, die wilden 90er, wir hatten gar
nichts und meine Hoffnung ist im Endeffekt
durch diese wilden 90er ein Umdenken
selbst der Putintreuen zu bewirken.
Ulrike! Jetzt noch mal
zu dieser Diskussion. Ja, das erste
ist Handelskrieg ist auch Krieg. Punkt. Ja,
den sehen wir nicht so, der ist
sublimiert da, aber wenn wir da hier die billigen
Tshirts kaufen usw in Bangladesh
sterben auch Kinder oder stürzen die Gebäude
ein und das sehen wir halt nicht,
weil die nicht jeden Abend im Fernsehen sind.
Im ZDF, ja, und weil wir es auch nicht
sehen wollen, weil wir das schöne T Shirt
wollen. Ja, aber Handelskrieg, sagt
man in der Soziologie, ist auch Krieg.
Und das zu verstehen, was schon mal
das erste, ja, das zweite ist bei Deniz
anzusetzen. Regime Change. Ja,
da habe ich ein kleines Problem mit.
Als wir die Apartheid gemacht
haben, haben wir kein Regime Change gemacht,
sondern wir haben gesagt, wir machen
keinen Handel mit Südafrika.
Und deswegen sozusagen werden
wir die irgendwie so austrocknen,
dass die ihr Regime changen und das ist
ja was anderes, dass wir sagen, nein,
wir machen keinen Handel, also du
setzt dein Verhalten, setzt du bei dir an,
aber du hast nicht den moralischen
Impetus zu sagen wir changen dein Regime.
-So war das nicht gemeint.
-So war das nicht gemeint. Dann mags so
-sein, aber so wurde es gesagt.
-Wobei ich das mit dem moralischen Recht
-das ist-
-Das ist ja eine Völkerrechtsgeschichte,
-die nicht-
--Geschichte, aber das Kriegsverbrechen und
diese Verbrechen gegen die Menschlichkeit
übersetzt eigentlich Verbrechen
gegen die Menschheit, das ist ja
nach dem Nationalsozialismus und im Zweiten
Weltkrieg ist das ja im Völkerrecht
etabliert worden und es gab auch gut
begründete militärische
Intervention, das, dass das auch nicht besonders
demokratische Vietnam in Kambodscha
einmarschiert ist, um das Morden der Roten
Khmer zu beenden. Und Syrien
war völkerrechtlich auch nicht sauber.
Trotzdem war das richtig. Also es war
ja nicht der- Das Problem beim Irakkrieg war
ein anderes. Ich will nur ganz
kurz, dass wir ein bisschen versuchen zu uns
zu sortieren, wenn wir noch mal ganz
kurz bei Russland bleiben können. Danach gehen
wir aufs große Ganze und gehen noch
mal auch über Lieferketten und Strategien
und Welthandel insgesamt. Ich wollte
nur noch mal genau diesen Punkt aufgreifen.
Jetzt die Frage nach Regime Change,
also wenn er aus dem Inneren kommen soll,
also wenn die wenn die Bevölkerung
quasi in die Lage versetzt werden kann,
einen Regime Change hinzubekommen.
Glaubst du Katia, dass Boykotte dabei helfen,
weil vielleicht die Not größer ist
und die Leute dann sagen Jetzt reicht's,
wir brauchen jetzt hier einen
Neuen oben. Glaubst du, das hilft? Wie ist
deine Erfahrung? Auch aus Belarus
zum Beispiel. Erst mal möchte
ich auch dahingehend sagen
Belarus ist auch ein eigenständiges Land,
was von Russland zu trennen ist.
Die belarussische Bevölkerung hat 2020
mit der belarussischen
gewaltfreien Revolution gezeigt Sie sind
gegen diese Diktatur. Sie haben
wirklich alles in ihrer Macht stehende getan,
um zu zeigen, dass sie diese Diktatur
so schnell wie möglich aus Belarus raus haben
wollen. Und das sind beispielsweise
solche heißen Momente in bestimmten Konflikten,
wo dann eben auch genau solche Boykott
und genau solche Sanktionen aus dem Westen
hätten helfen können, zum richtigen
Zeitpunkt den richtigen Leuten eben
zu helfen. Und das sind da die Belaruss*innen,
die gesagt haben,
sanktioniert dieses Regime, weil nichts
ist schlimmer, der Leidensdruck ist so
groß, wenn du nicht gesehen wirst,
wenn du das Gefühl hast, du bist den Ländern,
die es wirtschaftlich eigentlich
könnten, dir zu helfen, dass du denen einfach
absolut egal bist. Und deswegen glaube
ich, ist es fatal zu denken,
dass ausschließlich ein Boykott
jetzt da zu einem Umdenken führen wird.
Und gleichzeitig ist ja aber der Wandel,
dass dort bestimmte Produkte nicht mehr
verfügbar sind, dass dort bestimmte
Apps nicht mehr zugänglich sind etc. etc.
sind ja für viele erst mal ein Anzeichen.
Okay, es ändert sich überhaupt irgendwas,
weil ansonsten würden die ja
wahrscheinlich einfach weiter in ihrem
quasi Daily Life drin sein, würden
weiter einfach ihren Tagesgeschehen nachgehen
und könnten sich somit mit dem Status
Quo einfach abfinden. Aber es geht mir
vor allem darum, dass wir aufhören,
die ganze Zeit nur über Russland zu reden,
weil es geht darum, über die Ukraine
und mit den Ukrainern zu reden,
weil diejenigen werden
gerade hier in Deutschland boykottiert
von der Friedensbewegung. Die Friedensbewegung
sagt Wir wollen um Gottes
willen keine Waffen und dies und das und jenes Ukrainerinnen
werden ausgeladen
von Demos. Selensky durfte auf der Friedensdemo,
durfte in seinem Video nicht
gezeigt werden. Andrij Melnyk, der ukrainische
Botschafter, wurde eingeladen
zu einem Konzert, wo nur russische
Künstler spielen. Also entschuldigt mal
bitte, aber hört doch mal den Betroffenen
zu. Dorothea. Ja, ich denke nur,
dass meine Position also wirklich
ganz klar ist, Sanktionen und Boykotte dort,
wo sie direkt das Regime treffen,
in staatsnahen Branchen und in Branchen,
die direkt Güter herstellen oder auch duale
Güter, die in den Krieg einfließen.
Absolut. Und nochmal zum Wandel
durch Handel. Wir haben zuerst einfach Handel
betrieben und Globalisierung
aufgebaut oder Raubtierkapitalismus ohne Anspruch
auf Wandel. Und das hat sich aber in den letzten
Jahren geändert. Wir haben nun
den Anspruch auf auf einem Wandel
durch den Handel und diese zarte Pflanze,
auch wenn sie erst spät gekommen ist,
die möchte ich nicht so vorschnell zerstören.
Und ich finde, wir haben auch eine Verantwortung.
Wir haben nämlich
auch Abhängigkeiten geschaffen. Die Leute
in Bangladesch, die hängen davon ab,
dass wir die Tshirts kaufen. Klar
würden wir sie besser für 50 € pro Stück kaufen
als für 5 € pro Stück. Aber wir können
die Leute nicht zuerst in die Abhängigkeit
führen und dann einfach sagen: Jetzt
haben wir ein Sinneswandel. Cut! Und wir haben
immer die Ressourcen, uns anderweitig
zu versorgen. Aber für diese Länder, das ist
nicht alles China, das sind
nicht Giganten. Ist es nicht so einfach,
dann neue Lieferketten aufzustellen
und neue Wirtschaftsmodelle aufzubauen.
Wir haben unser Gewissen sehr schnell
damit beruhigt, aber wir haben Macht
und wir haben Verantwortung. Und wir haben
diese Bredouille mitverursacht durch
unsere neoliberale Globalisierung.
Und jetzt ist es Zeit, das zu ändern,
aber nicht durch
Deglobalisierung. Das heißt du. Du plädiert dafür-
Verantwortung. Also Boykotte sollten
mit Augenmaß, mit einem Verantwortungsgefühl
verbunden sein, auch abgesehen von dem aktuellen
Russland Angriffskrieg. Ja,
aber das finde ich gerade echt
schwierig an der Diskussion. Wir können doch nicht
über Tshirts aus Bangladesch
im gleichen Maße über die Ukraine
und die Friedensbewegung reden.
Also das ist sozusagen ein Problem
der Fragestellung. Reden wir über
Russland, reden wir über das. Ich bin
jetzt zu dir gekommen, weil ich jedes-
Ich habe das jetzt auch die letzten Tage
ein paarmal geschrieben an verschiedenen
Stellen über diese blau gelbe deutsche
Heimeligkeit. So habe ich das genannt,
wo die Ukrainer nur stören, weil die deutsche
Ukraine Solidarität, die könnte so
schön sein und so heimelig sein, wenn nicht
immer diese komischen Ukrainer
dazwischen grätschen würden. Und weil wir jetzt
gerade dabei sind, wollte ich jetzt
einfach mal zu dir kommen, weil das ist
jetzt einfach ein anderer- Ich finde
das schwierig, das auf einen Nenner
zu diskutieren über Tshirts und Lieferketten
aus Bangladesch. Ich übrigens
auch. Deswegen habe ich gesagt, wir bleiben
am Anfang bei Russland und gehen
danach- Das musst du uns zugesteht.
Also wir reden jetzt sehr, sehr viel darüber,
dass einfache Menschen in autoritären
Staaten leiden. Aber das Ding ist
zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo die anfangen
zu leiden, zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo die Welt
etwas merkt, wo die Welt genug hat von dem Scheiß
und einschreitet. Zu dem Zeitpunkt
haben die Menschen gegen die sich
dieses System richtet, schon extrem viel mehr
gelitten. Die sind vielleicht tot
alle. Vielleicht werden sie gefoltert,
zwangsgeschwängert,
zwangssterilisiert, alles mögliche. Also erst mal das sollte
der Fokus sein. Zweitens,
wenn wir wirklich so Herzblut haben
und diese Leute. Ich wusste, ich bin gut,
-aber-
-Nach drei Fragen alle zusammen.
Wir können vorher Feierabend machen.
Aber auf jeden Fall. Zweitens, wenn wir.
Also ich bin ja auch nicht herzlos.
Wenn wir wirklich an die Menschen denken,
die in diesen autoritären Regimen
von diesen autoritären Regimen leiden.
Das Ding ist: Je später wir eingreifen,
desto mehr leiden sie. Weil ich habe es ja
selbst mit Bosnien gesehen Milosevic
wollte zehn Jahre lang nicht einlenken,
hat Kosovo angegriffen,
Slowenien angegriffen, Kroatien angegriffen,
Bosnien angegriffen, vier Jahre
lang inklusive Genozid, dann wieder Kosovo
angegriffen und er musste, nachdem er Druck
ignoriert hat, nachdem er Sanktionen
ignoriert hat, nachdem er alles
mögliche ignoriert hat, musste er weggebombt
werden. Das war für die Menschen
in Serbien viel größeres Leid,
als dass sie Sanktionen hatten,
welche ihnen ehrlich gesagt nicht viel bedeutet
haben, weil Jugoslawien sowieso ein Scheißland
war, wo es nichts zu kaufen
gab. Also wenn man nicht früh
genug einschreitet mit dem Argument,
die einfachen Menschen werden leiden,
dann werden die einfachen Menschen am Ende
sterben. Und das haben wir auch in Deutschland
gesehen, dass Nazideutschland
weggebombt werden musste, weil davor
eine Appeasementpolitik herrschte. In ganz
vielen Ländern, nicht überall,
glücklicherweise aber in ganz vielen Ecken
und Ländern war so: Euer Hitler tut
ja uns nichts an, warum sollten wir jetzt
gegen Deutschland kämpfen? Ich glaube,
man kann die verschiedenen Konflikte schon
ein bisschen differenziert
betrachten, aber ich verstehe deinen Punkt absolut.
Das ist genau die entscheidende
Frage. Jetzt geht ja der Konflikt aus Russland-
Der wird ja jetzt weitergetragen. Wir wollen
unabhängiger werden von Öl und Gas.
Jetzt reist der Vizekanzler nach Katar
und geht von dem einen Dilemma zum nächsten
Dilemma. Man muss von dem einen
Autokraten oder von einem Diktator zum nächsten
Autokraten gehen. Was heißt das jetzt,
was du gerade gesagt hast? Wenn du das jetzt
ummünzt, heißt das kein Gas aus Katar.
Weil Katar ist nun menschenrechtsmäßig
auch mindestens fragwürdig.
Gerade bei Katar ist das Problem nicht
nur die Menschenrechte, also die Menschenrechtslage
in Katar selber. Da ist
Katar nicht mal das schlimmste Land in der Region.
Katar ist einer- Mit so einem
ideologischen Überschuss bei den anderen
in Afghanistan, in Syrien- Also Katar ist
einer der der globalen
Exporteure des Islamismus.
-Was heißt das ist?
-Das ist viel dramatischer als nur die
-Menschenrechtslage.
-Und das ist doch genau die Frage, die wir
uns jetzt stellen müssen Was bedeutet
das jetzt? Also wenn wir jetzt irgendwie
eine Orientierung suchen, heißt
das, wir dürfen jetzt Gas kaufen von denen
oder nicht? Darf ich mal was sagen?
Ja, also zu den schlimmsten Sowjetzeiten.
Wir wollen nicht behaupten, dass die Sowjetunion
irgendeine Form von Demokratie
war. Aber zu den schlimmsten Zeiten
ist das Gas immer geflossen. Wir haben 1981
haben wir die Sowjetunion, die Olympischen
Spiele boykottiert, weil es ein heißer
Krieg in Afghanistan war. Und auch da ist
die Frage nicht thematisiert worden.
Ich bin für eine eurasische
Friedensordnung, würde nur gerne darauf
hinweisen, dass wenn wir jetzt
Fracking Öl machen in Amerika, machen wir Krieg
gegen die Natur. Und insofern
sind natürlich die Option tatsächlich
eigentlich weniger. Wenn wir nicht
nach Katar wollen, nicht nach Irak wollen,
Saudi Arabien oder Fracking, dann
müssen wir gucken, wie kriegen wir die Ukraine
jetzt erst mal unmittelbar
befriedet? Was sind die Lösungen? Und zwar morgen,
in zwei Wochen? Wie auch immer
sofort, dass das Leid aufhört, bin ich sofort
-dabei.
-In der Frage nach der Ukraine gibt es auch
überhaupt gar kein Vertun. Es ist
vollkommen eindeutig und das ist
auch klar. Aber ich würde trotzdem
gerne die Grautöne ausloten. Vielleicht kriegen
wir ein Kriterium ab wann man ab
welchem Grad der Menschenrechtsverletzung
oder der Kriegseinwirkung, ab wann man
sagt da ist ein Boykott gerechtfertigt,
da eher nicht. Wo ist das Augenmaß?
So jetzt die Frage an euch ist das Vorgehen
des Vizekanzlers in dem Fall
richtig? Oder wäre es richtiger zu sagen: Nee,
wir boykottieren natürlich diesen Staat
auch, weil wir haben ja jetzt gelernt,
wir wollen eben nicht mehr
diese Abhängigkeiten haben. Was würdet
ihr sagen? Angenommen, ihr wärt
Kanzlerin oder Kanzler? Ich sage genau das,
was ich vorhin schon gesagt habe:
Wir haben das zu lange wuchern lassen
und jetzt stecken wir mitten in der Scheiße.
Und wir müssen jetzt,
weil es ohne möglich ist, alle,
alle, alle autoritären Regime komplett
zu boykottieren. Jetzt müssen
wir Abstufungen machen und jetzt müssen
wir gucken. Okay, das ist zwar ein scheiß
Regime, es ist auf einer Skala von 1
bis 10, vielleicht sieben.
Scheiße. Deshalb machen wir vielleicht sieben
Boykott Niveau. Interessant. Genau
das ist ja die Frage. Also das ist das,
-was wir spielen.
-Sondern Fußball WM. Die könnte man ja
relativ problemlos boykottieren. Also
ich finde, dass man ein wichtiges Signal.
Das ist unfassbar. Vor allem
jetzt Olympia Spiele in China. China ist
das Paradebeispiel. Also
jahrzehntelang wurde ignoriert, was sie ihren eigenen
chinesischen Dissidenten antun, was sie Tibetern
antun, was sie Uiguren antun seit
Jahrzehnten. Und Taiwan, Hongkong
usw. Und jetzt sind wir in einer Situation,
in der China zu der Weltmacht gerade
wird. Wandel durch Handel hat nur dazu geführt,
dass die noch mächtiger wurden durch
den ganzen Handel. Und jetzt haben sie-
Die machen mittlerweile den ersten
Hightech Genozid in der Geschichte
der Welt, wo sie Gesichtserkennung
haben. Und künstliche Intelligenz die Ethnien
der Menschen sofort erkennt
und eine Datenbank mit 75 verbotenen
Verhaltensweisen. Und dann
machen sie das so weiter und sie verkaufen
das an Diktaturen weltweit. Und jetzt
sind wir in der Scheiße, weil jetzt hat so
viele Diktaturen weltweit, haben jetzt
einfach Wege um ganze Bevölkerungsgruppen
auszurotten auf ne Hightech Art und Weise.
Und was machen wir? Wir kaufen immer noch
Sachen von China. Wir machen
da Olympia Spiele.
-Wir verkaufen unsere Sachen.
-Volkswagen hat mitten in China ein Werk.
Wer arbeitet da, wo er arbeitet? Ganz
transparent. Ein Plädoyer, um das richtig
zu verstehen ist.
Handelsbeziehungen abbrechen? Ja, also zum Beispiel
mit China. Wir haben ja gerade gesagt,
es gibt vielleicht so eine Skala von 1 bis 10
Diktatur scheißemäßig. China ist da bei elf.
Okay. Das heißt, da würdest du sagen,
General-Boykott wäre angebracht?
Absolut. Würdest du das unterstützen? Darum geht
es mir. Ich will ja genau die Grenzen.
Wo sind wir jetzt? Artur geht wieder
auf die andere Seite.
Zu dir komme ich gleich.
Ich finde das hier so nett. Jetzt
in dem Kreis. Dann lassen wir das. Lassen
wir doch- Okay, jetzt will ich das auch wissen,
weil mir geht es ja genau
um diese Grautöne. Also, dass wir uns
in vielen Punkten absolut einig sind,
ist eindeutig klar. Aber was machen
wir jetzt in Zukunft? Also China, sagst du,
Handelsbeziehungen abbrechen? Das ist
eine Diktatur. Bis elf müssen wir raus. Hab
-ich richtig verstanden?
-Diese, ich zitiere dich,
Diktatur-Scheiße-Skala von 1 bis 10
unterstütze ich, die kann auch bis zwölf
gehen oder so, die Dimensionen
werden manchmal gesprengt
und innerhalb von der könnt man ganz
klar definieren. Eben Stufe eins der Sanktionen
ist, was ich irgendwie natürlich das erste
Rüstungsgüter, Stufe zwei in Finanzströme.
Danke für den Hinweis. Stufe drei etc.
Und dann diese Eskalation. Weil dann führt
es auch nicht zu einem
abrupten, ungeordneten Rückzug, wo man dann
die lokalen Leute, bei denen doch
vielleicht ein bisschen was von dem Geld
der internationalen Wirtschaft auf dem Konto
gelandet ist, das führt dann eben
auch nicht dazu, dass diese lokale
Bevölkerung einfach über Nacht im Sumpf
gelassen wird. Ich muss
jetzt mal zu Artur rennen. Bist du
bei der Diktatur-Scheiße-Skala
von 1 bis 10. Bist du dabei?
Ich bin dabei. Mein Problem ist,
gerade im Kontext des Konfliktes, ob wir jetzt
gerade China in Grund und Boden
sanktionieren können, weil wir gerade
in diesem Konflikt, in dieser Konflikt
Spirale zwischen Russland und der Ukraine
spielt ja China eine wichtige Rolle
und ich glaube jetzt ist nicht der Zeitpunkt,
um China zu sanktionieren, irgendwie,
oder zumindest könnte man ihnen das androhen.
Aber ich glaube, wir müssen
jetzt irgendwie Gespräche finden,
um diesen Konflikt doch zu beenden.
Weil China und Russland haben
wie eine Bündnispolitik in irgendeiner
Art und Weise und da müssen wir einen Weg
-finden, wie wir damit umgehen können.
-Und würdest du sagen, in Zukunft, mal
angenommen, das wäre die allergrößte
Hoffnung, vor allem für die Ukraine
natürlich, dass es bald Frieden
geben könnte in irgendeiner Form. Wir würden
es uns so backen, es würde so
passieren. Würdest du dann sagen Gut, jetzt haben
wir das erreicht, jetzt sanktionieren
wir China? Ja, das wäre der nächste Schritt.
Das wäre der nächste Schritt.
Potenzial. Aber wir müssen. Unser Problem ist halt,
wie Melina schon gesagt hat, wir haben
ziemlich viel verpasst. Wir hätten schon
früher härter reagieren sollen.
Jetzt haben wir den Salat und jetzt müssen
wir Abstufungen machen. Und deswegen bin
ich rübergegangen. Aber wir können jetzt
nicht eine Sanktion gegen China
erwirken. Man kann jetzt auch nicht die Türkei
-in Grund und Boden sanktionieren.
-Weil alles mit allem zusammenhängt. Auf
-jeden Fall.
-Na ja, und weil China noch mal eine andere
Nummer ist. 1,3 Milliarden ist was anderes
als Was hat Russland jetzt 143 oder so?
Ja, das ist einfach- Das muss man
schon auch mal sehen. Ich bin dabei. Aber
das kann eigentlich nur darauf
hinauslaufen, dass man sozusagen
Globalisierung irgendwie
neu denkt. Ja, wirklich neu.
Artur zustimmen oder nicht?
Ich frage deswegen Ich versuche
nur zu differenzieren. Strategisch
jetzt möglich oder sinnvoll wäre, China
zu sanktionieren. Das kann ich jetzt
nicht beurteilen. Ich wundere mich einfach über
diese Zeitenwende, nachdem wir jahrzehntelang
auf eine globalisierte,
integrierte Welt hingearbeitet haben.
Diese Bereitschaft, jetzt einfach wieder
uns in Blöcke aufzuteilen und die Illusion
zu denken, ich nenne das eine Illusion,
dass wenn man wirtschaftliche
Beziehungen kappt, dass dann doch noch
ein kultureller, wissenschaftlicher
Austausch stattfindet. Das ist dann ja
auch weg und wir haben
transnationale Probleme, die wir lösen müssen.
Stichwort Klimawandel. Und wenn Staaten
sich abschotten in Blöcke etc., dann,
dann wird diese ganze Zusammenarbeit
wird so viel schwieriger gemacht. Also da bin
ich auch ein bisschen zu harmoniebedürftig,
aber ich sehe einfach
nicht, wie wir in einer Welt,
die in krasse Blöcke aufgeteilt ist,
diese wirklich krassen
Herausforderungen bewältigen sollen. Nur eine ganz kurze
Ergänzung mit einem sehr treffenden
Beispiel Ein Freund von mir, der gerade
in der Ukraine ist, der hat
mir, der war am Anfang richtig gerührt
von diesen großen Solidaritätsdemos,
die hier stattgefunden haben. Und jetzt hat
sie gesagt. Ich habe kein Vertrauen
mehr in Europa, weil das, was wir machen,
dieses ganze Herumreden, dieses ganze
boykottieren wir jetzt boykottieren
wir jetzt nicht. Das ist ein Zeichen
von Wir waren und sind es bis jetzt noch nicht
bereit real an der Seite der Ukraine
zu stehen und die Ukrainer*innen merken,
dass die kämpfen da gerade
allein, die verstehen, dass die einzigen
Möglichkeiten, die sie haben von uns
sind letztlich noch Waffenlieferungen,
weil auch über close the Sky, das wurde
ja mittlerweile auch schon längst alles
abgetan. Die Leute fühlen sich allein
gelassen, der Großteil der Geflüchteten.
Wir sagen Jetzt kommen hier so
viele Geflüchtete an, nein, der Großteil
der Geflüchteten sind
Binnenflüchtlinge, die jetzt im Westen des Landes sind.
Und die Leute fühlen sich von uns
allein gelassen. Und mit jeder Minute,
die wir hier mit unserem Arsch im schönen,
warmen Deutschland im Prinzip weiter
diskutieren können, sterben dort
Menschen, sterben dort unsere Freunde und werden
weiterhin Menschen in Belarus
gefoltert, weil diese ganzen Systeme zusammenhängen.
Und deswegen geht es mir darum, wir müssen
boykottieren und wir müssen einfach gerade
alles tun. Und es muss wieder alles
auf dem Tisch liegen, damit wir den Menschen
dort vor Ort real helfen, damit
dieser Krieg vorbei ist. Und da möchte
ich im Prinzip einfach nur darauf
hingehen ist, wir müssen die Ukraine
in unterstützen und das können wir nur wenn.
Eigentlich müssten hier viel mehr
ukrainische Stimmen auch gerade
stehen, wenn wir darüber sprechen, wenn wir über
die Türkei sprechen vielleicht.
Ich glaube, ich glaube auch. Und das ist,
glaube ich auch, dass das eine Erkenntnis
aus dieser, aus dem Versuch
einer Diskussion über eine allgemeine
Orientierung in Sachen Boykotten Solange
der Krieg in der Ukraine so weitergeht,
wie er weitergeht, ergibt das gar nicht so
viel Sinn. Das haben wir jetzt
mehrfach von euch auch gehört. Also in dem Fall
sind wir uns auch alle einig von Anfang
an gewesen. Vielleicht, vielleicht war
es auch einfach ein einfach
gescheiterter Versuch, jetzt in die Zukunft zu denken
und darüber nachzudenken Wie gehen
wir jetzt mit Erdogan um? Was machen
wir mit Katar? Was ist mit China in Zukunft?
Weil momentan dieser Konflikt
einfach alles überlagert und deswegen glaube
ich auch diese Diskussion
vollkommen
nachvollziehbarerweise überlagert.
Nach dieser Sendung habe ich für mich
das Fazit gezogen. Das habe ich aber
auch schon vorher irgendwie
gezogen, nur das es noch mal bestätigender ist:
Wir haben den ewigen Frieden mit dem Frieden
verwechselt und der ewige Frieden
ist eine Illusion. Ihn gibt es nicht
und wir müssen immer irgendwie uns versuchen
zu wehren. Also die Demokratie
muss wehrhaft bleiben und wir müssen
ein Verständnis davon bekommen,
was in anderen Staaten abgeht. Das ist
-meine Position.
-Die für mich als Fazit nach dieser
Diskussion wäre auch noch mal
festzuhalten, Autokratien und Diktaturen
nicht einfach als Status Quo zu akzeptieren,
sondern Frühwarnsysteme
zu entwickeln, unsere Demokratie
hier in Deutschland zu stärken, aber
auch die demokratischen Kräfte in anderen
Ländern zu stärken. Und das sollten
wir auch tun, wenn es uns hier
gerade wirtschaftlich vielleicht wehtut.
Und ich muss jetzt gehen. Das war
schön mit euch. Wirklich? Ja, ich muss. Das ist
dein Schlusswort? Das ist mein Schlusswort.
Ja, auch so habe ich genug
geredet, sonst bin ich Scheißigkeitsskala,
das ist ein Wort, was ich von heute
mitnehme. Großartig! Aber zitier mich!
Aber natürlich. Danke. Ich sage herzlichen
Dank für eure Teilnahme. Ich weiß, es war
anstrengend und es war auch chaotisch,
aber ich glaube, am Ende des Tages
bleibt doch die eine oder andere Erkenntnis
hängen. Vielen Dank dafür. Danke
schön. Ja, das war wirklich- Das war
die besonderste Sendung, die wir jemals
hatten. Eindeutig.